an incredibly worrying situation across
many european countries but particularly
in west germany and belgium in the area
of germany i mean the arvila district
local authorities are saying some 1300
people
are still missing and the rescue
services are mounting intensive
operations to find them now it could be
at least some of those people
are found safe and well because one of
the problems at the moment is the power
networks are down
phone networks are down there's
virtually no internet connectivity and
we've spoken to relatives
who have been trying to get a hold of
their loved ones
for hours some of them have found
people safe and well but others are
still trying to make
those connections now a particular focus
for the authorities and rescue services
at the moment is two dams
that are causing concern one is near the
belgian border that flooded overnight
another dam has become unstable so
clearly
engineers and other experts are going to
be looking into
those dams in the situation and they're
evacuating homes
around the areas we also know that
overnight
a number of homes collapsed in a village
south of
cologne people are being told not to try
and return to their properties and get
out of their properties but
many people just want to stay port they
want to see their houses
stay safe but it is incredibly dangerous
because the rain is still falling
river levels are still rising the road
networks um transport links are all
interrupted so as i say a very worrying
situation indeed and a massive operation
for the rescue services